Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Richard Lops, and
today I'm here for another episode of my series
Humanizing Sex Workers, and I'm here with Vanny Hall.
She's an award winning trans adult content creator, entertainer,
and sex worker, and she's also the host of
Sex Tales, together with Melissa Stratton. And so we're
going to talk about trans women in the sex
industry today and some misconceptions that people might have
about them. So Benel, welcome to the show. It's
a pleasure to everyone.
Thank you. Thank you for having me. I'm so
excited to be here. Thanks for inviting me on,
Ricardo.
No, sure, it's a pleasure. So, uh, before we
get into trans women in sex work or the
sex industry, tell us a little bit about your
story, your personal story. I mean, because I'm interested,
I, I've talked on the show. With, uh, sees
women mostly with in this series that you're the
first trans trans woman, so I'm interested in, uh,
understanding, uh, first of all what it is like
to, um, be a trans woman and also what
it is like to be a trans woman in
the sex industry. So what got you into pornography?
Um, I've always been like a porn consumer. Uh,
BEFORE I was transitioning, I was a person that
enjoyed porn, um, um, but I never felt like
I would see myself in porn. And as I
transitioned, I saw even less of people that looked
like me, um, especially in the early, early years,
you know, I was very flat-chested, um, and You
know, there just wasn't a lot of like non-giant
tittied women in porn when I was younger. And
I remember when I turned 18, I was very
excited to start streaming and to start getting into
um a sexy mode of myself because I remember
not seeing people like me before and I knew
that there was a market for it if I
was looking for it at one point. Then there
has to be other people that were looking for
it as well. So I decided to sort of
like put what I wanted to see in the
world a little bit and, and, and be uh
the porn girl that I wanted to, to, to
see. Um, SO yeah, um, I started transitioning when
I was like early like 16, uh, like transitioning,
uh, but really, um, really conservative, um, state and
conservative, uh, household. Um, MY mother is a Southern
Baptist preacher, so, um, I was very like little
bits, tiny little bits here and there, mascara, foundation,
things like that, and it just kind of built
up over the time, um, but I
really, so was it particularly hard in that kind
of environment?
It was hard, but I do think that I'm
a particular type of person that like doesn't really
like ingest what people tell me, um, especially if
they like have some perceived authority. I just like
it just bounces off of me. I don't, um,
don't do what people tell me to do, and
I especially don't, and I especially do like the,
the complete opposite sometimes, um, so I've just always
been that person and I've always been super hyper
feminine, um, like from the jump. And I think
it was just one of those things that like,
everybody knew that if it just like, if it
was left, left to their own devices, that it's
what would happen and yeah, it just happened.
Uh, SO back when you got into the porn
industry, the visibility of trans women in sport was
not that, uh, great yet, if I understand it
correctly, right?
Um, I, I suppose so. Um, I have to
be honest with you, I'm not. I didn't, I'm
not like a sports person. I've never, the only
time I've picked up a ball is when someone
threw it at my head, so I threw it
back at their head. Um, THAT'S that's the only
like real dabbling in sports that I have ever
had. Um, I didn't really like, it didn't come
into my sphere until like 2 or 3 years
ago, um, when the whole trans debate started kicking
off. Um, BUT to be quite honest, I'd never
had any. Interest in sports or like um like
I didn't like watching them either. I found them
boring, so I was pretty shocked with the whole
trans debate, uh, trans sports debate because I, I
didn't know any trans people who were in sports.
I didn't even really know any trans people who
were like watching sports, so I've always been like
a little on the outside of that debate, um,
and just sort of like. Truthfully kind of just
confused as to what everybody is so in arms
about, so
yeah, but, but in the porn industry specifically, I
mean, do you see that over the years it's
become easier or people have become more accepting of
trans performers or not?
Um, I, like I said, I don't actually like
do temperature checks and like make sure people like
me, um, before I do things, um, but I
do think that trans people have become more visible
in the last couple of years, um, on like
the mainstream stage, um. I I, I, I don't
know. I don't get any more. I mean, I,
I still get the same amount of You know,
dick that I did before. Again, there's been not
like a giant increase and there has been a
giant decrease in the type of guys and the
guys that are into me. Um, IT'S I I
find that the whole debate to be like unfocused,
um, and confusing, um, from the outside looking in,
it just kind of feels like people um have
this, these perceived uh preferences and they're just kind
of like Letting them govern how they want to,
you know, tackle sports and bathrooms and everything. Um,
AND I think that people for the most part
haven't really let that affect what they ingest sexually,
what they ingest in their you know own private
time. Um, AND yeah, I can't say that like
The money is any worse or any better. Um,
IT still feels, but it definitely does feel consistent.
It doesn't feel like no one's stopping their ingesting
of trans porn, and no one has stopped calling
me or texting me. So you know. Yeah, but,
but, uh, but when, when it comes to when
you came into the porn industry, do you have
any idea as to whether, uh, trans performers, particularly
trans women, have more obstacles to overcome when coming
into the sex industry than cis performers, or is
that something that we, you didn't really experience?
Oh yeah, 100%. I think that. Trans bodies are
just seen as like less profitable just in general.
Um, I think that there's been a default to
straight content for a very long time in the
industry. Um, MOST tube sites that you go to
will default to straight, white, like able bodies that
are Aren't too chubby, aren't too skinny. Like, it's
been a very much of the same thing for
a very long time. Um, AND I knew going
into the industry that I would have that barrier,
um, and that ceiling really, that I couldn't really
compete with a cis girl because I don't know
if this is like a secret or anything, but
cis woman can film like 56, scenes a day,
um, uh, and I cannot, I can see, I
can do like 1, maybe 2 if it's like
a really, really tough day, and that week I
can do maybe, maybe 3, but most trans girls
that I know in the industry kind of do
1 a month, um. Because we don't have the
same, you know, we don't have the same plumbing
and the same things aren't expected of us that
are expected of cis women. Um, WHEN you are
on hormones, hormone replacement therapy, the, uh, Can I
say penis?
Yes, you can use that word. Yes,
the, the, the penis, uh, is not as able
anymore. It becomes less and less able the longer
that you take hormones. Um, SO when you're expected
to, um, come on demand and like be hard
on demand, that is not an easy thing for
a trans person. Um, THAT is actually like pretty.
Borderline like impossible for most, um, and it's really
like a skill and like a muscle that trans
performers have to flex in order to do these
things. But again, we cannot do them at the
same rate. Um, SO there just will not be
the same amount of scenes. There just won't be
the same amount of girls. Um, THERE'S just like,
it's such a small pool already, you know, um,
and I think that it's, it has just Its
own challenges and everybody, especially um in different areas
have their own challenges. I know that being in
New York City was like a major like Flaw,
um, that director saw for me because most trans
girls are either in Vegas or LA, um, and
if you weren't like right down the street where
they can get you, then they just weren't about
to call you. Um, SO I think that if
I were a cis, uh, female, I would have
an easier time in the industry, but it's still,
it's still a grind, you know, it's still one
of those things that like you have to work
for. And you have to continuously work for, um,
you know, no matter what your body type is.
So, and when it comes to the people you
perform with, uh, I'm asking you this because I,
I know nothing about these aspects specifically and when
it comes to the porn industry, but is there
any sort of stigma attached to, for example, male
performers who do scenes with trans women in the
sense that they tend to be, to do exclusively
scenes with trans women. AND not, not with cis
women because they are sort of looked down upon
because they perform with trans women, or is there
something like that
there? Yeah, definitely there's like a look down stigmatized
upon it, but also the amount of guys that
will perform with trans women are a smaller pool
in the first place. So when a trans studio
does find male talent that likes shooting with trans
women. They do actually pay them more than um
they would get paid if they just were doing
straight content um so it's like a little bit
of like a double, a double edged sword a
little bit because you get to, um, you know,
you get to perform and you get to have
a steady paycheck, but you You have the knowledge
that if you were to go into the mainstream,
you would be seen as less than, and you
just simply would not get paid as much and
you don't get paid as much, not because you
filmed with trans people, but just because you're male
talent. They just don't value male talent in the
same way and there's just so, so many. And
I'm going to be honest, straight dudes that are
willing to bang straight chicks, um, you can find
them, you know, down the road. So when there
is a guy that does perform with trans people
and is able to perform, trans studios really hold
onto them for dear life.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, but, but I mean, does it
have anything to do with the fact that the
cis women performers also don't really like to perform
with those male performers because they have sex with
trans women? I mean, I mean, is there anything
like that in the industry? She'd
be
told
I've never been confronted. With that, no one, no,
uh, uh, performer in the industry has ever told
me that directly, that they have those issues. They
have told me that their agents have those issues,
that their managers have those issues, because they are
thinking in this way of this giant web of
like what you can do and what you can't
do to get however much money, like your first
anal scene has to be, you know, like your
8th scene in order to get this much money
type of thing. And I think that They see
it as like the value of their performer depreciating
if they, you know, um, perform with someone that
has performed with someone that is considered less than,
um, but I do think that that is something
that's like an industry thing, um, especially since the
industry does not see trans bodies as profitable. They
just, and even gay bodies, um, they just, uh,
You know, they, they, they impose these sorts of,
uh, rules and restrictions that um Most cis girls
are, are, aren't just going to like go break.
Uh, THAT'S just they're not just going to go
because there's no real reason to, like there's no
real, like if you're getting paid well and like
their only stipulation is you can't work with trans
people, then, you know, I, I, I can't necessarily
fault them for that. But I, I mean, I'm
sure that there are people that have these biases,
but I've never been confronted with it, um, and
I've also never really like Um, Felt a need,
you know, to work with those people. Um, IT'S
really not going to be a good scene if
you're not into it. It's really not going to
be a good scene if you're like feeling like,
you know, your manager is going to be upset
at you for doing it. I really, I, I
don't care. I do not care. Um, AND if
it's not going to be a good scene, then,
you know, you should go do something, something else,
I think. I don't know.
Mhm, YEAH, uh, but I mean, do you feel
like, uh, trans women in the porn industry is
something that is a positive form of visibility, even
more particularly so in the past few years where
uh the consumption of. Trans porn has been going
up and up, or do you think that there's
perhaps an element of sexual fetishization there? Oh,
it's all sexual fetishization. My highest spenders are people
who, when I go and find their personal Instagrams
and personal Twitters. ARE filled with what I would
be considered these sort of like alt right um
thoughts, um, these thoughts that I would consider to
be directly opposing to me as a person. And
I've had really rough nights reconciling with that, um,
reconciling with the idea of giving pleasure to people
that don't see, um, a reason for me to
exist in society. Like how does that really work?
Um, BUT I do. You know, I do have
the knowledge and can actually speak to people and
realize that they As much as they have their
preferences and the way that they feel about the
world. They also Enjoy the type of content that
they enjoy, and sometimes they don't even really have
an answer as to why they like it, um,
but they do, and then, and they can't really,
you know, they, they can't really stop that. Um,
SO that's really the only, like, um, the part
of it that I really, uh, care about, um,
is the, the, you know, If people are going
to, you know, be searching up everything about me
anyway, be digging up things on me and be
trying to find out if I'm a terrible, awful
person, then I do think that they should at
least be paying a subscription price, um, and have
to, to, to actually access me. They need to
be, be, be, be lining my pockets, um, because
I can't say that representation. IS an amazing thing.
I can't say the representation has made people more
accepting of trans people. Um, I can't say that
seeing more trans people is making people more accepting.
Um, BUT I also can't live my life for,
you know, waiting for acceptance. Um, IF you can't
accept me, then you're going to have that, that,
that's not going to change the fact that you're
going to have to pay me. I'm not going
to stop living my life and stop doing the
things that I want to do because you don't
want to see me in this capacity anymore. It,
I just can't do it.
Mhm, BUT you feel then that perhaps compared to
cis women, there's more of a of an element
of treating trans women as simply sex objects in
the sex industry.
Oh, totally, but I, to be honest, I don't
think it's different for cis women. I don't. I
think that most, a lot of men see. Ciss
women, especially cis porn actors as objects, um, and
they talk about them as objects and they, they,
they treat them as disposable when they do something
wrong that they don't like. They, they, they think
of all women in the same way. Um, I
don't think it's different. I don't.
Yeah, uh, so what do you think are perhaps
the most common misconceptions that people have about, uh,
trans performers, particularly trans women? I mean, when you,
have you ever been confronted with people, uh, making
this or that claim about, uh, trans women performers
that you thought, oh, OK, this is just ridiculous.
God, um. Jeez, uh, ba ba ba. Well, I
know, yeah, I know for a fact that people,
um, in the industry just don't think that trans
content is profitable and that trans bodies aren't profitable,
and I've been profiting off of my own body
for a very long time now, um, and I've
been doing very well for myself off of just
my body, off of a body that Half the
time does not work um the way that it's
supposed to, um, but when I can like set
up a camera and I can make, um, make
my body work in a certain way and I
can upload that content and I can make money
from it, then like I'm like I'm golden over
here, um, but yeah. I feel like I completely
forgot the question.
Uh, uh, uh, NO, it was about misconceptions, but,
but then let, let me ask you about this,
uh, let me ask you about this specifically because
I think it's a misconception not only for applied
to trans women in the sex industry, but trans
women more generally. I mean, and, uh, people have
this very common idea, uh, that, um, the gender
identity in this case. For you it's a trans
identity as something to do with uh sexuality that
sometimes it's not so much that people identify as
the opposite gender, it's just that they have this
sort of sexual kink or something like that. I
mean, is there any, is there any connection at
all between gender identity and sexuality?
I mean, definitely, for sure, I think that there's
probably something, but I do think that there exists
two separate groups of of of queer people, let's
just say. Um, I do think that trans women
are different than people who dress up in women's
clothing for sexual gratification. Um, I think that when
a man or someone who perceives himself as a
man puts on stockings and a skirt and a
corset and a wig that they got from the
dollar store, and they jack off in front of
the mirror and then they you know go burn
that stuff or throw it all in the trash,
I think that that person is a very different
person than someone who At the age of 1213,
slowly started doing these things that people around them
saw as feminization, but they themselves just saw as
expression. They themselves were just trying to express. And
I think that when people express femininity. It's looked
down upon. It's especially people who are perceived as
men, when they express femininity, it's seen as weakness.
It's seen as, why would you want to accept
weakness? And I think that that is a hard
thing for people to reconcile with. Like why would
you not be doing this for sexual gratification. Why
would you not be doing this for a small
moment in your bedroom alone in the dark? And
that's because it's not, it's not just for me
and it's not for anybody else as much as
it's like for my soul. Like my soul wants
to dress up in this way. Once these clothings
that you were telling me are wrong, but I
can't really stop myself from liking the things that
I like and being the way that I am.
Like I just don't think that's, you can't stop
someone whose favorite color is green to say, Oh
my God, I love that color. You can't, you
can't. And like that's A different thing than someone
who's Than someone who jacks off when they see
the color green. Like it's, it's, they are two
different things and I understand the fear of like,
oh, these people are objectifying me further and kind
of making fun of me further. But I, as
a person who is not interested in women, who
is not, who does not see women as sexual
as that sexual of beings, I don't have those
feelings. I don't think that I need Stockings and
panties and a bra in order to feel sexy,
in order in order to stack off in the
nude since I was young, in the nude, I
have felt very feminine. It's where I felt my
most feminine and it's always been my most feminine,
and that's that's why I started taking nudes of
myself, because that's where I felt that I can
express myself. The most, like in the most feminine
way. And it's never been about the hair. It's
never been about the makeup. It's never been about
the clothes. Those things have come later. Those things
have come societally. Um, YOU know, I wear certain
things to the grocery store because people look at
me weird if I don't, you know, I know
what society expects of me, and I think that
people, they get them really jumbled up of people
who, you know, trying to exist in a society
and trying to be seen as sexy. You know,
maybe to to to their local crush and people
who who find all of this to be a
giant like thing worthy of jacking off for. That's
just, that's not me.
Mhm. Yeah. Yeah, it's really interesting. So, uh, did
you feel that uh after you transitioned and uh
started presenting yourself even more feminine, do you think
that, um, in, in what ways did you feel
people treated you differently? If they treated you differently,
of course. It was kind of almost immediate, um,
because like middle school, I was super hyper bullied,
like physically bullied, um, like people chasing me and
trying to, trying to hurt me, trying to like,
I don't, I don't even know, just trying to,
to tease and hurt and like call me out
in the middle of lunch type things and like,
As soon as high school hit and I made
a decision to partake in the things that I
feel are feminine and partake in the way that
I want to behave in the world, the way
that I changed, the way that I moved in
the world did not change, but the way that
people treated me changed immediately. And I don't think
it was because the femininity, it was per se,
but it was because Like the femininity was something
that I was trying to hide for so long.
It's something that everyone could see, but that I
was trying to put this veil over and pretend
wasn't there. And I think when I decided to
put that femininity in front of me and decided
to say, You know what? I do like the
color pink. You know what? I do like frilly,
I do like frilly things and just start incorporating
that little and little, people just, they shut up,
they stopped, and then they started hitting on me.
Then I started getting catcalls in the in the
hallway and like just like like guys that fully
were bullying me three years ago, like, you know,
without their buddies around and without anybody around, grabbing
me at my waist and trying to like whisper
shit into my ear and I'm like, bro, you,
I thought you hated me. I thought this was
like disgusting to you. And like, and you know
anyway, um, I fully Had to accept myself in
order for it to become my shield in order
for it to become the thing that like makes
me powerful instead of the thing that makes me
weak, um, and that's definitely I've taken that to
how I move in the world because I think,
I, yeah, I know that if I presented differently,
if I tried to hide this and try to
present myself as a cis man, as a man
that's, you know, I'm just a dude, I think
I would have a hell of a lot more
trouble in this world. I think that I would
not be um probably even alive because of the
trouble that I would have in this world. Um,
AND I don't think that it's me being a
trans woman that's made me, um, you know, hard
to Hard to, you know, knock over. I think
it's my acceptance that I myself may be a
trans woman. Um, IT'S the acceptance that I myself
am not some alpha male, um, that that gives
me that power, I think.
But, but, but do you think that if you
were a sales man, because as you said, you
were always, uh, more feminine than the average man
that you would have been into, into more trouble
because, uh, people, I, I, I mean people would
treat you as would have treated you as a
weak man. Yeah, yeah,
they would have treated me as, as just like
an extremely weak man that just can't be a
man or something. Um, THEY could, they would, and
I don't even, yeah, yeah, I think, especially because
I was never into women, I was never, um,
I was never like a a person that like
chased skirts and like. I just, um There's no
way that I would be able to, you know,
survive in that world as, as a cis man,
and um Yeah, yeah, I am. I was really
depressed as a kid, especially when I was, you
know, the really repressed times. I was a really,
really sad and lonely individual, um, and I can't
help but feel like it's because you know of
the parts that I was denying to myself that
I could not find friends or even family that
I could relate to, um, that I could feel,
you know, that I could be myself around even
a little bit, you know.
Yeah, do you feel that that's perhaps one of
the reasons why some trans people decide to transition
later in their lives, like in their 40s, their
50s, sometimes their 60s, because they know that there's
a big risk that they will be rejected by
most people around them.
Yeah, they are worried that they'll lose everyone around
them that they've grown to love, that they've, that
they have grown. Into this person around, um, because
people are afraid of losing the people that they
love. They are worried of them becoming just completely
different people, um, and they, and to them like
transience is the ultimate, you know, like change, um,
and I think that's how I didn't realize how
people saw it. I didn't because I didn't really
change the person that I was on the inside.
I just started allowing the parts of my outside
to like show and um. Yeah, I think that
most people just, um, don't allow themselves to feel
that way until it starts getting a little quiet
around like 40, 50 years old, until people, you
know, stop coming around in the first place, maybe
as much and, and you don't have as much
pressures on yourself and not as many eyes on
you as a 20 year old, then you start,
you know, maybe thinking, you know, maybe, maybe I
can explore myself in a different way. Um. And
maybe I will. I have to lose people, um,
but maybe that's a sacrifice that I'm willing to
make.
But one thing that I heard when you were
talking about how things changed after you transitioned and
started presenting yourself socially as a woman is that
you mentioned, for example, being more catcalled and people
trying to grab you and things like that. So
do you think that you having made that transition
Also allowed for you to get a better understanding
of perhaps what it is like to live as
a seized woman in our societies and people uh
uh because someone is a is a woman, people
thinking that it's easier for them to take advantage
of them or something like that.
Yeah, yeah, um, yeah, I, yeah, um, yeah, I.
Yeah, uh, it wasn't, it wasn't long until, it
wasn't long after that that I remember feeling that,
um, I had to be careful, um, that I
actually shouldn't wear too short of skirts, um, around
everyone, um, that I actually shouldn't, um, be alone
with a bunch of guys, um, sometimes, um, and
that I actually shouldn't, you know, uh, be out
on in, in like a club or in a
bar or anyplace, you know, by myself, um, all
the time, just because, um, there has been Um,
there's been a time where I have been roofied,
um, and, you know, realized before anything happened and,
and, and went home, um, like this is after
high school, but, um, there's been times where I've
been grabbed, um, in the middle of the street,
um, and only because my friend who's literally directly
beside me, um, was there to help, was I
able to like stop, um, the situation. I, I.
Yeah, I think that there is definitely a vulnerability
in being a woman. Um. ARE being seen as
a woman, um, in society that is scary at
times. Um. Yeah, that's kind of all I can
really say about it, really. Mhm.
No, right, OK, so, uh, but since you are
a trans woman, but you're also a sex worker,
do you feel that there are ways in which
sex workers' rights might intersect with trans rights?
Sure, for sure, I think like most like obscenity
laws and like most um. Uh, LAWS against bodies
in general, any sort of type of body or
anybody, any part of the body being shown, um,
I think directly impacts trans people, directly impacts queer
people who just are seen as different. Um, AND
the same goes for, for, for laws against against
trans people. Um, I think when laws start saying
things like a person cannot, a person who is
seen as a man. Um, CANNOT, you know, enter
the woman's bathroom, um, is a very short, it
seems very short and sweet, and why would anyone
have a problem about it, but you have to
take into account that there are a lot of
women, a lot of women who identify as women
who have never identified as anything else, who just
look like men, who have short hair, who have
Faces that look like men. There are a lot
of men. There are a lot of women that
just so happen to kind of look like men,
and they are fully women, and they identify themselves
as women, as cis women, and You, there's no,
there's not enough gray area to um. To justify,
you know, um, Legislation on people's bodies. There just
isn't. Um, AND we as sex workers have dealt
with a lot of legislation on the showing of
our bodies and on being sexy, making, you know,
kind of like being sexy on the internet illegal,
and we, um, We already like can't work really
in these, you know, conditions. So I, I hope
that people will like um Start seeing the fight
against um Against transphobia as a fight against, you
know, people being anti-sex work and also being anti-woman.
Like I don't think that, I don't think that
all women look one way. I don't. I don't
think that all women have, you know, the same
degree of testosterone in their body. And I don't
think that because me as a person is looking
to experiment and looking to, you know, be in
the world. And not hurt anybody around me. I
don't think that because I'm looking to do that,
that means that every woman should be blood tested
and like genital checked. That's Crazy, I think. I
think that that's berserk. I think that the people
that need to know what's in a person's pants,
um, usually are the people that the person is
dating and needs to have that conversation with. That
is, that's the conversation needs to have between two
people. I don't think it needs to be legislation,
and I don't think it needs to be this
giant debate on whether every woman. Needs to drop
their pants and show or prove to you that
they're a woman. I, I think that that's ridiculous.
No, I agree that's absolutely ridiculous, and I mean
when it comes to the debate surrounding public bathrooms,
I think that first of all, as you said,
there are women out there, even if they are
in the minority that are that have really masculine
features, sees women, and, and so I mean what
are you going to do? Are you going to
assume that any woman who looks a little bit
more masculine than you think a woman should look,
can't enter women's bathrooms. And then when it comes
to trans women specifically, I mean if they are
forced to go into, if they are forced to
go to men's bathrooms, I mean, aren't you also
More easily target a target of harassment there because
I'm a trans woman in the middle of a
bunch of men. I don't think that's very safe.
No, it's not very safe, and it obviously shows
that they either don't care or they are hoping
that trans women get hurt, that these, that these
people that they're, that they are still seeing as
weak men. Um, YOU know, get, get, get roughed
up a little bit, and I, I feel unsafe
at times in the middle of New York City,
in the middle of the street, and I cannot
imagine at my age being the way that I
am now, going into the middle of a men's
restroom. Um, THAT sounds terrifying to me, absolutely horrifying.
Um, I'd much rather hold it. I will hold
it or I will pee in the bushes, but
I will not be going in the men's bathroom.
Yeah,
yeah, and when it comes to sex work, I
have, I have also this sense from the conversations
I've had with other people on the show and
even um off camera that it also has a
lot to do with uh people trying to policing
or controlling women's sexuality more generally, right? I mean
it's, it's basically. People trying to say, oh no,
we, you as women, whether you are cis women
or trans women, you should, you shouldn't be allowed
to express yourself, yourself sexually in a free way
or however you want, or at least in this
specific way.
Facts, for sure, it's all about control or perceived
control, and like I. I think that a lot
of politicians and people that vote for these legislations
and cheer on these legislations want that sense of
control over women's bodies. They want to feel like
they have control in this small part of this
world. Like I, I don't think that you should
kill babies. So therefore, nobody should be able to
have an abortion. And that's That's the choice that
I'm sticking to, and they want to like feel
like a big man that's in control. And honestly,
we can't continuously like have legislation and have a
world that like, Puts that guy on a pedestal,
that makes that guy like, you know, the guy
to, oh, that's a good guy. No, that guy
obviously has nefarious motives and isn't just thinking about
protecting women when he's saying things that are anti-abortion
and anti-woman.
Yeah, which is funny because you also sometimes see
feminists, not all feminists, of course, it tends to
be the radical, the radical branch of feminism who
are trans exclusionary but also sex worker exclusionary. So
I mean even though they're women and most of
them sees women at the same time they seem
to place themselves on the side of patriarchy when
it comes. To policing women, other women's sexuality and
whatever other women have in their pants, I guess.
Oh yeah, no, they, and they place themselves on
a pedestal, a hierarchical pedestal as well against these
women who they see as less than because they
allow men to do things to their body and
they say things like, you're male-centered because you let
a man pay to, to have sex with you.
And I'm sorry, but there's nothing male-centered about like
Deciding to feed your child in the way that
you have. Um, AND I don't think that that's
male-centered at all. I think that people have a
very small scope of what they consider to be
What they consider to be OK. And I think
we smallen that scope more and more when we
start putting things, like we start agreeing with them
about ways that there are ways to be a
woman and there are ways to be um a
proper woman, because it just it just goes smaller
and smaller and smaller, and they're like, Oh, actually,
you're not, you're not a proper woman. You sell
your body. And how can a woman do that?
It's Buffoonery, complete buffoonery.
Yeah, there's lots of moralization going around there, right?
It's like, oh, I'm morally superior to you because
I don't do these degenerate kind of sexual things,
right,
right, and they completely negate that there's reason beyond
someone's sexual pleasure that they're in sex work, like
the terrible job market that we are currently in,
and the terrible economy that like most people. Cannot
survive off of one job in their city, in
their state. Most states are still at 750 minimum,
and that is not something that most people can
survive one person on, let alone a child, another
child. Like it's It's a hard world out there
and you act like you don't understand why someone
would need to do something that you would consider
unsavory. Like. There's money, dude. People need money.
Yeah, yeah, and I also think that there's lots
of hypocrisy going around in society because for example,
if you look at data coming from Pornhub, I
mean, uh, Transportorn, people have been watching more and
more Transport and. Equally so in the more conservative
states. So it seems like it seems like the
same guys who present themselves publicly as transphobic than
in their private lives are watching trans girls on
the internet.
So it's the same guy. It's the exact same
freaking guy. I sometimes will go through my comments
on Twitter and I'll look at reply guys and
I'm like, let me see what you actually post.
And the crazy replies and stuff that they're, they're
like, oh my God, they like literally will comment,
I love your big giant dick under my photo,
and I'll go to their replies, and the next
thing that they commented on the next person's post
was that trans people should not be allowed outside
in society. And I do have to admit that
I don't think that they're like, um, I don't
think that that's completely a Like I think that
the reason that he holds this belief that trans
women should not be able to go outside and
not be able to exist in society is, is
it because he is secretly not into trans people.
It's because he's into trans people and he wants
one like kind of captive, kind of not able
to have any sort of choice, any sort of
actual Um, other thing that they possibly could be
doing other than being a pleasing object for him.
He does not think that trans people shouldn't exist
wholly. He thinks that trans people shouldn't exist in
this way that he doesn't like. And that's the
problem is that people think they can pick and
choose how someone can exist, how groups of people
can exist. And you know there's been people in
this world that have thought that before, um, and
we had worked for them. So.
Oh, that, that's really interesting. So do you think
that perhaps there are some guys out there that
they really like trans women but perhaps they do
not feel really comfortable er seeing them on the
street because I mean, they might look at them
in a particular way that gives away the fact
that they are attracted to them and they don't
want other people to learn about it.
Exactly, yes, exactly, 100%. The amount of like, uh,
like. Oh, I want to sex you up looks
that I get from people, and then I'll get
an immediate death glare from them after that because
I'm watching them realize that they should not be
publicly into me is crazy, berserk, absolutely fuck wild
because like, dude, do you really care that much
what a person thinks about you that you don't
want to get your nut off? And also, why
am I like Why am I in this? Like,
I'm just a girl on the street at the
end of the day. I don't actually, I'm not
actually going to have sex with you, dude. Why
are you having this whole internal battle about me?
Mhm.
Yeah, no, it's, it's, it's funny because at the
same time that some of these guys again publicly
have an opinion or present themselves against trans women
and even against sex workers, they also think that
sex workers are just women that are. 24/7, all
the time sexually available, even to them, to them.
Yeah, they think that they think they find this
to be objects. They're like, Oh, I want to
pick this one off the shelf, and they don't
care if they're like advocating for that shelf to
be brought down and the whole fucking building to
be brought down. They still want your ass on
that fucking shelf when they want it. They're still
going to be like, Wait, why, where are all
the girls? Like they, and, and in these crazy
conservative states, like, I was in um Minnesota, uh,
like a couple of weeks ago, and the amount
of people that came up to me in public,
which I was shocked with. I was like, Whoa,
wow, you chill like that. Y'all chill like that,
but by themselves and stuff. But like still, the
amount of people that came up to me. And
this like what I would consider to be very
conservative state, a place where I have seen like
bathroom bans like on the, like, on the McDonald's,
like, don't go in here if you type shit.
And people are coming up to me and like
asking for my autograph. And I'm like, wow, I
don't know if like the repression is making it,
like making people more excited to ingest it, or
if this is just how it's how it goes.
People who are interested in this content or who
are interested in things that they don't feel like
they should be interested in. Or just like, trying
to pretend like they're not interested in it? Is
that just the way that that life has been?
Like, is that what people just do? It kind
of just feels like it.
No, yeah, it's, it's funny. So let me ask
you just to get into one last topic. Do
you think that porn performers can play a role
in things like sex education and educating people about
sexual health, because, you know, usually people associate. Pornography
with something that's dirty, but for example, I've had
Nina Hartley on the show, and she's, apart from
having been a sex worker, a porn performer, she's
also a sex educator, and she has a series
on sex education. She has a book on it.
So do you think That porn performers, even though
people tend to attach them to uh aspects of
sex that are a little bit dirtier than than
what we see regularly, that they can still play
a role in that. Oh,
100%, and I think that people, even if they
are thinking that, um, That sex workers are, you
know, dirtier and worse than them are like, um,
they are excited to take that advice from, from
sex workers who, who have good advice. Um, Lisa
Ann has a Amazing voice and does amazing things
in a sexual wellness. Um, AND she's in a
sexual wellness, uh, world, and she does like lectures.
Um, AND she is an amazing porn star, and
she's, she's great. And I think that 100%, um,
I think that we have a unique Um, view
on the world and on sex. And I think
that a lot of people don't, they, they live
for better or worse, they don't really want to
think about it. They don't want to like do
the dirty, uh, research and the dirty, um, you
know, on the ground reporting, um, that it sometimes
takes to actually, you know, to, to talk about
some things, um, to talk about the dirty, the
dirty, gross stuff. Um, AND I think that, yeah,
sex workers are uniquely Um, inept, uniquely able to,
to, to give those views. Um, SO yeah, sex
workers are the best sexual wellness coaches for sure.
Yeah, OK, great. So, uh, would you like to
let people know where they can find you and
your stuff on the internet? Totally,
yeah, you can search Vanil on Google if you
want, just V A N N I A L
L, or you can search me on Instagram or
Twitter under the name Vanil with three L's, that
is V A N N I A L L
L. And yeah, wherever else you get your porn,
I'll be there.
OK, great. So look, it's been really fun to
talk with you. Thank you so much for coming
on the show.
Oh, no problem at all. Thank you so much
for having me.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Muller, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingbird, Arnaud Wolf, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inasi Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herz Agnon, Michel Jonathan Labrarinth, John Yardston, and
Samuel Curric, Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel,
Sardusran, David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego
Londono Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro,
Adam Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka, Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov,
Zal Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward
Hall, Eddin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolotti, Gabriel P
Scortez or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony
Smith, and Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg
Jarno, Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophanous, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin,
David Williams, Di Acosta, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex
Shaw, Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D.
Lee Junior. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber,
Robert Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix,
Mark Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly
Johnson, Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson,
Ismael Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate
Van Goler, Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali
Mohammadi, Perpendicular, Jane Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David
Pinsov, Sean Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A
special thanks to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank
Lucas Stink, Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller,
Thomas Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlomon Negro,
Al Nick Cortiz and Nick Golden, and to my
executive producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and
Rosie. Thank you for all.